more than a century after first emerging
into the fog-bound gas-lit streets of
Victorian London Sherlock Holmes is
universally recognizable even his
wardrobe and accessories are iconic the
Inverness Cape deerstalker hat and
calabash pipe and figures such as his
best friend and housemate dr. Watson
arch nemesis Moriarty and housekeeper
mrs. Hudson have become part of the
popular consciousness as have his
extraordinary infallible powers of
deduction utilized in the name of the
law his notorious drug use and his
popular catchphrase elementary my dear
Watson and yet many of these most
recognizable features of Holmes don't
appear in Arthur Conan Doyle's original
stories Doyle's great detective solves
crimes in all sorts of ways not just
using deduction he speculates and at
times even guesses and regularly makes
false assumptions furthermore mrs.
Hudson is barely mentioned no one says
elementary my dear Watson
and the detective and his sidekick live
apart for much of the time Moriarty the
grand villain only appears in two
stories
the detectives drug use is infrequent
after the first two novels and Holmes is
rarely in thrall to the English legal
system he much prefers enacting his own
form of natural justice - sticking to
the letter of the law finally many of
the most iconic elements of the Holmes
Ian legend are oils either the
deerstalker cap and cape were first
imagined by Sidney Paget the story's
initial illustrator the curved pipe was
chosen by American actor William
Gillette so that audiences could more
clearly see his face on stage and the
phrase elementary my dear Watson was
coined by author and humorist PG
Woodhouse so who exactly is Sherlock
Holmes
who's the real great detective and where
do we find him purists might answer that
the original Sherlock inspired by Arthur
Conan Doyle's University mentor dr.
Joseph Bell
is the real one but the fact remains
that that version of Sherlock has been
largely eclipsed by the sheer volume of
interpretation leaving Doyle's detective
largely unrecognizable
so there's another more complex but
perhaps more satisfying answer to the
question but to get there we must first
consider the vast body of
interpretations of the great detective
since conan doyle's first story in 1887
there have been thousands of adaptations
of Holmes making him perhaps the most
adapted fictional character in the world
that process began with Victorian stage
adaptations and accelerated with the
emergence of film there were more than
100 film adaptations of Holmes in the
first two decades of the 20th century
alone and since then there have been
many thousands more in print and on film
television stage and radio Homes has
been reinterpreted by people everywhere
in remarkably different and often
contradictory ways these adaptations
demonstrate both Holmes's popularity and
his malleability for instance he
featured in a number of Allied anti-nazi
propaganda films during World War two
and both Winston Churchill and Franklin
Delano Roosevelt were avid enthusiasts
the latter even joining the Baker Street
Irregulars a holmes ian appreciation
society and nicknaming one secret
service hideout Baker Street and yet at
the very same time Holmes also appeared
in various German language film
adaptations some of which were said to
have been much-loved favorites of Adolf
Hitler so let's return to our question
with the real Sherlock Holmes please
stand up the truth is that this world of
adaptation has made him into a
palimpsest Sherlock is a cultural text
repeatedly altered over time as each new
interpretation becomes superimposed over
those that preceded this means that
Sherlock continually evolves embodying
ideas and values often far removed from
those found in Conan Doyle and after
each particular story ends Sherlock
rises again a little changed perhaps
with a new face and fresh mannerisms or
turns of phrase but still essentially
Sherlock our Sherlock